[Music]
hello welcome to the first and only
episode of mathematical baking with Toby
today we're going to be making some
delicious ancient Babylonian
mathematical tablets now Babylon was an
ancient city whose ruins lie in
modern-day Iraq and the ancient
Babylonian civilization was among one of
the first to be able to write they did
this by inscribing things onto clay
tablets which could then be baked in a
kiln and sit hard and made permanent or
they could just be left uncooked and
recycled hundreds of thousands of these
tablets have been excavated from the
ruins of the civilization and many of
them relate to mathematics in fact many
of the tablets found by archaeologists
were preserved by chance in baked when
attacking civilizations burned down the
buildings in which they were being kept
before we get baking we first need to
cover our bases when it comes to ancient
mathematics when we're talking about
numbers writing 2 3 4 is very different
to writing 4 3 2
so in our number system it depends on
the position of each digit specifically
when we write it like this it is really
saying 3 times 10 and 4 times 100 in
fact we can rewrite this number as being
equal to 4 times 10 squared which is a
hundred plus 3 times 10 plus 2 now our
number system is in a base of 10
probably because we have 10 fingers and
it's easy to start counting over again
once you reach 10 but not all number
systems have a base of 10 you could
pretty much have you know whatever
number you want for example if we had a
base of 7 any of the numbers higher than
7 could be re-written using the digit 7
or lower for example if we have
that can be written as 1 times 7 plus 2
now let's talk about the ancient
Babylonians they didn't use a base of 10
or of 7 instead they used a base of 60
now you might be thinking what kind of a
crazy base is 60 but we actually use it
sometimes too for example telling the
time we've got 60 seconds in a minute
and 60 minutes in an hour so he can
probably thank the Babylonians somewhere
along the way for that one for the
Babylonians base 60 they had no symbol
for zero and the other fifty nine digits
were written as a combination of only
two markings in the clay made with some
kind of square-ish tool it appears they
had the wedge for the units and the
corner for the tens they wrote numbers
less than 60 like this this was a 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 20 30 40
50 and 59 and then when we reach 60 we
start again so 1 which is 62 witches
could be 2 60s 360s 10 60s would be a
corner and 59 60s would be 5 corners and
9 witches if we had this it would be
equal to 12 and in our base 60 that
would be times 60 squared because it
does depend on the position plus this
which is 31 but that is times 6
see and then adding on this that will be
plus 25 now all of that will be equal to
and I did this calculation before for
five oh eight five so this is how
ancient Babylonian mathematics works and
we're going to use that to see if we can
decipher some of the clay tablets now of
course there is a little bit of room for
miscommunication here because say one
which could be interpreted as one or as
sixty and something like a corner and
two wedges because there is no symbol
for zero this could be ten eleven twelve
or it could be ten sixties
so it would be 602 we're not really sure
but we'd have to follow the context of
the rest of the calculation to be a bit
more confident now we're going to take a
bit of a break from the maths a little
bit of a mental break and we're going to
do some baking
instead of using clay I'm going to make
a gingerbread tablet and then we're
going to inscribe some cuneiform onto it
that is the name of this babylonian
writing so we're going to recreate one
of the original tablets which have
helped us to really understand how the
ancient Babylonians did math now in
terms of ingredients I have them laid
out here I've got three cups of white
flour half a cup of brown sugar
two thirds of a cup of molasses a
hundred and seventy grams of butter and
then some little spices and things I've
got one teaspoon of baking soda one
teaspoon of ginger half a teaspoon of
cinnamon 1/2 a teaspoon of nutmeg 1/2
teaspoon of salt and some chili I've
also got this egg here and we're just
going to mix all of these into this bowl
[Music]
[Music]
now that I've finished mixing all of
this together I'm actually going to put
it into the fridge for a few hours to
let it cool so I'll see you then once
it's cooled for a bit I need to roll it
out and get it to about the size of my
baking tray I was aiming for it to be
about one centimeter thick I then put it
back in the fridge overnight I wanted it
to be nice and firm for the inscribing
process for my tools I used a chopstick
for the wedge cymbals and a cocktail
skewer for the corners
[Music]
this is an image of the original tablet
we will be replicating and here is a
clearer version of it I then made some
lines I'm not going to tell you straight
away what the purpose of this tablet is
because I want to give you a chance to
work it out
you know everything that you need to
know but one hint is that this strange
group that repeats in every line with
the strange sideways symbols that isn't
a number that's a word so we have 10
something 110 then something to 20
something 330 something 440
something 550 I'll tell you what the
word is it's the word for multiplication
this is a multiplication table and in
the top left corner they've told us that
it was the 10 times table notice when we
have 10 times 6 we get one wage to
represent 60 ten times seven equals one
wage in one corner to give seventy ten
times 12 is equal to two wedges for a
hundred and twenty and that's all I had
space for then I put it in the oven for
about 10 minutes at 175 degrees Celsius
here's what the baked version looks like
next to the original and here it is with
a bit more of an authentic look it's not
bad actually I might offer something to
my family but their collective response
will probably be what the heck is this
that I enjoyed making it and there's
actually a lot more that can be said
about ancient Babylonian myths and a lot
more that we can learn so I'd love to
make some more videos like this granted
that you enjoyed this one so please let
me know down in the comments or leave a
like and I hope you have an absolutely
mathematical day
[Music]
you